una ecologista calcula la edad de 100
árboles en un bosque local usa un
diagrama de caja para graficar sus datos
como se muestra a continuación cuál es
el rango de edad de los árboles que
calculó cuál es la mediana de la edad de
un árbol del bosque primero que nada
vamos a asegurarnos de entender lo que
nos dice el diagrama de caja esta es una
manera de ver ampliamente el conjunto de
datos en este caso la edad de los
árboles y también nos da otra
información como por ejemplo cuál es la
mediana y donde se encuentra la mayor
parte de las edades de los árboles
podemos ver que este es un brazo
esta es la caja y aquí hay otro brazo en
esencia lo que nos dicen los brazos es
cómo se dispersan los datos que tenemos
vemos que el valor mínimo de nuestros
datos en esta muestra es un árbol de 8
años suponiendo que este eje de acá se
refiere a la edad en años y el árbol más
viejo es de 50 años si queremos el rango
nos referimos al rango desde el punto de
vista estadístico es decir el valor
máximo menos el valor mínimo será
entonces 50 menos 8 que es igual a un
rango de 42
y esto es lo que nos dice en los brazos
nos dicen que todos los datos están
entre 8 y 50 incluyendo 8 y 50 años
ahora lo que hace la caja permíteme
explicarlo de esta manera esta recta de
en medio es la mediana lo voy a escribir
aquí mediana entonces la mitad de las
edades va a estar de este lado de la
mediana vemos que la mediana es de 21 lo
que nos dice el diagrama de caja es que
la mitad de las edades de los árboles
son menores que 21 y la otra mitad son
mayores que 21 estos extremos aquí son
las medianas de cada una de estas
secciones así que esta es la mediana
para todos los árboles que están por
debajo de la mediana principal es la
mitad de las edades de todos los árboles
que son menores de 21 años y esta es la
mediana de los árboles que son mayores
de 21 años esencialmente estamos
dividiendo la información en cuatro
grupos a esto vamos a llamarle el primer
cuartil y es aproximadamente un cuarto
de los árboles que dependiendo de cómo
hacemos el cálculo un árbol puede estar
en un lado o
más o menos una cuarta parte de los
árboles está aquí otra cuarta parte de
los árboles cae entre 14 y 21 otra
cuarta parte cae entre 21 y 33 y el
último cuarto va a caer en este último
cuartil este es el primer cuartil este
es el segundo cuartil este es el tercer
cuarto y este es el cuarto cuartil para
responder a las preguntas ya calculamos
el rango de edades el rango es de 42
años la diferencia que hay entre el
árbol más joven y el árbol más viejo y
la mediana de la edad de un árbol del
bosque es de 21 años aunque tenemos
árboles que tienen hasta 50 años la
mediana del bosque está más cerca del
extremo más bajo de todo nuestro
espectro de edades si vemos a la mediana
como nuestra medida de tendencia central
está apenas en 21 años y podemos
observarlo está más cerca del lado
izquierdo de la caja y del extremo del
brazo izquierdo que en el extremo del
brazo derecho